- What do you think of Jason's costume?
He was playing flute
for you on your way out.
- Now, Jason is dressed as?
- As a leprechaun.
Just for you.
- Oh, I see.
So Jason is Scottish?
- He.
(laughing)
- I'm sure the people of Ireland
aren't offended at all.
- Nope, nope.
- It's pretty good,
the hat fits perfectly.
- Thank you.
- He reminds me of my, my
friend, Ken Jeong, who,
I have, I've helped him in his career.
I, I also, he dressed up as a,
almost, very similar
outfit like a year ago.
(laughing)
That's, there he is.
- Yeah, no,
I actually am Irish.
My people hail from Cork, Ireland
- Really?
(ringing)
- What?
- Is this Cork, Ireland calling?
- This is Cork, Ireland.
- Oh, that's great.
(laughing)
- It's not Cork, Ireland calling.
You'll be hearing from my lawyers, Joel.
Not funny, that is my lamb,
bring my lamb back.
Hi Kelly.
- Hi!
- Love you, miss you.
Happy Saint Patty's Day.
- Wow.
- I hate you.
I want my lamb back.
- This first of all, Ken,
thanks for dressing up
for this, whatever it is.
- Says the guy in a jersey.
- True.
- That looks nothing like me.
That looks nothing like me.
How dare you?
- Yeah,
you know what, a lot of people,
I'm always like Ken Jeong does not age,
he's always looked 60.
(laughing)
- Okay.
All right.
I'm gonna call my lawyer right now.
I love you Kelly.
- I love you, Ken.
- Happy Saint Patty's Day.
- This is.
- I hate every thing you
stand for, Joel, good bye
- We have a podcast.
Where's that?
Wow.
- He just left.
I think he just hangs
out in our Skype room
to just join the show when he wants.
- I did not know that was gonna happen.
- I know.